spent some time in qatar on this trip
haven't you
yes that's right
sorry let me point out
let me point out that there's been no
pre-interview and i have no notes okay
because you really helped with that yes
that's right
all right listen did you spend some time
in qatar on this trip
okay i thought it was qatar am i wrong i
don't know
hey sorry i did a uso tour i did a
little bit of a military tour there to
sort of
you know raise the spirits or lower the
spirits of the troops
and uh they were calling it cutter okay
you're right cutter sorry
cutter i was saying it wrong yes i was
there
look i don't know what happened and it
wasn't me
i was only there for two days okay
everything's fine but here's my question
you got to be very careful in a place
like qatar
uh because they are very strict about
drugs even drugs that we may consider to
be rather
mild drugs aubrey you know what i'm
talking about
what like the mary jane
yeah i know that you like to puff on the
old
weederoo once in a while you like a jazz
cigarette occasionally
first of all that's legal in california
baby you heard it here first
right it's legal in california but you
take one of your
gummy bears and you know the kind i'm
talking about
you take one of those to cutter you take
one of those to the middle east you
could end up in jail for 15 years
they'll take away your sunglasses look
full disclosure
i this was beaten into me before i got
on the plane to cut her
they told me do not test it aubry
and i said fine i'll eat all my gummies
in the car ride over to the airport and
i did
and then i got to the airport and i
found out that we were delayed three
hours
see normally you get into the airport
and you get on the plane and you just
fly
right high into the sky
this time i ate the gummies went into
the airport
met guy ritchie and stayed them for the
first time and then was
very quickly told we had a three hour
maybe four hour delay
and i had to break the news to them
mommy ate some gummies
you being mommy yeah so you told them
mommy ate some gummies
and then you tripped out didn't you i
mean
you were feeling no pain tell you what i
did on my gummies
what i do on my gummies is my own time
no business business
i don't know what happened okay i know
that we eventually got on the plane
and now we're shooting a movie
that's all you need to know you know
what do you what else do you need to
know you're in turkey
you have no gummies on you right now yes
you're in turkey
okay good oh what else you really
tripped me up
it really tripped you up